now my understanding was is that you're
going to in this class reverse engineer
a script well into a book that's not
exactly what we'll be doing in the class
actually but it's something of great
interest that we could talk about a
little bit I I have had some modest
success in my career not just in in film
working and making a living as a
screenwriter but also publishing and
with major publishers for the most part
in my case all New York publishers the
publishing business still is mainly New
York just like Hollywood is still
Hollywood and on a several occasions I I
took something that I had written as a
film and in some instances that actually
had options gonna make some money on it
but had never really ever gotten it to
where I wanted it to be that is to say a
deal you know that that got made into
something that that audiences could
participate and what I did was use the
novel I'm sorry
use the screenplay as an elaborate
outline for a novel no writing is easy
but it's easier once all the heavy
lifting has been done if he bunts you've
written a screenplay you know who the
characters are you know almost all of
the dialogues certainly a lot of the
dialogue most of the dialogue the story
is all worked out you now have merely to
write it now I was on merely because
there's nothing near about writing but
it is easier to just put the words on
once will you have all of the incidents
of the events and the anecdotal stuff
worked out and then it becomes a
question in the description I have had
success at that that is to say couldn't
make the movie happen so wrote it is a
novel and then sold the novel as a novel
was able to get the novel published and
then suddenly there was interest in it
as a novel that is to say an adapted
novel adapted for for the screen
the the current my current gripe with
Hollywood with American film industry is
the the refusal to do original stuff and
well you can take an original screenplay
and turn it into a novel and then it's
no longer original now it's an
adaptation and that's what they they
prefer to do so you can kind of in a
sort of a Zen surrender sort of a way
hey make it what they wanted to want it
to be I also will tell you that I find
greater satisfaction in writing novels
they're less they're easier they're less
they're not easy but they're easier they
are more tolerant of inefficiency and
bad economy I'm not saying you should be
inefficient not economical I know when I
talk about economical I mean in terms of
moving story Freight moving character
Freight with a little bit of language
rather than the other way around and
you'll really get killed in a movie in a
screenplay if it's inefficient but in a
novel I think because the the viewer the
reader of the novel has the opportunity
to turn the pages faster or even to skip
over stuff or conversely to go back and
review stuff makes it somewhat easier
for the writer to to write it down and
as I've said that sometimes people say
me yeah but but but Richie and that was
a longer than a screenplay my last novel
and I know I'm bragging it made the
Times bestseller list
okay just number 13 and only for a week
but that's not a small thing
The Times list that was about two
hundred and thirty six pages a two
hundred forty five pages something that
in typescript I'm sorry the published
book so in typescript it was about three
hundred pages now a screenplay should
not be much more than a hundred pages
the last bring things are getting
shorter now which i think is good the
last job that I did I had an assignment
this past year and that script came out
I figured 93-94 pay
and it's it's full its complete and my
point is the reason I'm dwelling on
these page counts is it's easier to
write a longer thing than a shorter
thing and we seem counterintuitive but
think about it there's a famous letter
that Ernest Hemingway wrote he was in
Cuba living in Cuba and I believe he was
writing the old man in the sea one of
his later books wonderful book of course
everything he did was wonderful and in
the midst of working on the book he
wrote a long letter was nine pages long
to Maxwell Perkins the legendary editor
who worked with a lot of famous writers
including Hemingway and he was
discussing various aspects of the book
and whatever and at the end of the
letter he says well that's about it for
now max please forgive me for running
such a long letter I didn't have the
time to write a short one takes more
time to do what artists have to do which
is to cull and select and throw away so
much screenwriting education is about
structure and construction and building
up and I think there is some useful time
spent considering that but ultimately
creating dramatic narratives is not
about building up I think it's about
tearing down and taking away it's about
discovery this cover taking the cover
off and finding something that's already
there I never knew a writer I have a lot
of experience myself as a writer but
that experience is leveraged
exponentially by all the writers I've
worked with very intimately very closely
over you know now for 35 years here on
campus with writers in our advanced
graduate screenwriting classes but also
in the community I am a script doctor
I'm a pretty busy script doctor I give
notes to lots of writers no small number
of those writers have deals at studios
they're coming to me and saying you know
ask me the hard questions before the
producer asked some becoming more and
more routine I think in Hollywood
even when you have a deal to consult
with somebody before you actually submit
it to the to the studio and so having
done that has it has expanded my own
experience as I say exponentially and
I've never known a writer I've never met
a writer who wasn't surprised by things
that happened in her story by lines of
dialogue that a particular character
suddenly spoke it's as if it kind of has
a you know a life of it of its own